[Music]
new efforts to boost the strategic role
of bees in agriculture and protect
biodiversity are creating a buzz these
small busy workers ensure pollination of
over 80 percent of european crops and
wild plants
of course they also make honey too and
the products we derive from it
through the farm to fork strategy the eu
is investing in bees the goal is to
protect them and preserve their
contribution to sustainable
environmental models
to do so the eu is spending 40 million
euros a year to fund specific apiculture
programmes
we went to meet a beekeeper who runs a
family apriculture business and produces
around 400 tonnes of honey a year
for him taking care of the bees means
taking care of the environment as many
wild pollinators are threatened by
intensive agriculture pesticides
pollution and climate change
for us the main priority is to have
healthy bees in order to get a good
production
that's why even if we work in a
conventional beekeeping system we use
only eco-friendly and organic approved
an hour from bucharest we visit one of
the country's historic honey producers
the company is a pillar for the rural
economy as it collects honey from dozens
of local beekeepers and exports it to
the rest of europe the middle east and
asia
[Music]
the sustainable approach here comes from
a particular attention to quality
standards
honey samples are tested and certified
not only by romanian laboratories but
also by a specialized structure in
germany this level of control guarantees
the highest quality for consumers
[Music]
the main characteristics of our honey
production quality standards
are the lack of antibiotics
no adulteration the proper humidity rate
and the use of organic treatment
to follow legislation we must preserve
all our samples for a period of two
years and of course we abide by the law
so we have a hundred percent
traceability
[Music]
another innovative measure taken by this
company is its partnership with ice chim
one of the most important research
institutes in romania
for a long time honey's antimicrobial
properties and wound healing powers have
been known
by mixing different types of honey with
natural plants researchers here are
focusing on honey's therapeutic
qualities and developing new
applications for the medical field
[Music]
we had the idea of producing a type of
honey enriched with compounds
that make it similar to a medicine here
we obtain these compounds from forest
fruit pulp the pulp that's left over
after extracting the juice
a traditional and constructive practice
in the honeymaking world is the
transhumans of bees it consists of
moving beehives during the flower season
to pollen paradises near fields and
forests
the eu is trying to help in the
management of this practice as it's a
win-win for honey the future of the
environment and agriculture
[Music]
you